ciao guglielmo giorno la buccia e
continuo a dire a tutti da circa 24 anni
e che io sono vecchio caro come ma il
fatto è che non sono lecceprima mio
paura delle cure ma con questa scusa
nessuno mi offre il momento ma perché ha
paura di legumi ciao ragazzi benvenuti
alla nuova puntata di vita buttata il
tema di oggi è bugie per il tema di oggi
ho deciso di invitare qui in questi
studios una persona alla quale devo
dirlo raccontato forse la buccia più
grande della mia vita ossia che è una
mia amica graziana ciao v cerca letali
sette anni quando la scuola tra sempre
chiamare seguito perché fino a quando un
giorno mi accorsi che la volta della
particolarmente goccia per forza michel
velata per poco ancora agenda dal ea
chiederle che cosa fosse successo
il bravo genitore che educa maniera sana
mi spiace usare la forza e che quindi si
era gonfiato il ventre
dopo tre mesi nacque uno dei miei
fratelli io ho paura che non è un
braccio perché penso in mezz'ora il mio
mezzo umano ad aver paura ora danni a
casa nulla a farlo ho detto a mia madre
che sarei andata per una settimana con
gli scout a un campo
l'inverso
ero in belgio andato a trovare il
fidanzato il poker in erasmus cose che
ma vabbè ma già allora tutto bene una
bugia sono bugie della inception dello
studio
allora la bugia che avete detto è stata
quest'estate ai miei genitori certa del
mattino dove sei
riporto in piazza torno tra poco mentre
nella cairo a riccione e io sono di
modena entro tornato un po tardi e
questa cosa si potrebbe ripetere a sé a
magneti questo mese
ok allora diciamo che le più grandi
palle mele raccontate mia perché non so
che è praticamente una cosa credo un
quarto ragazzo di tutto la veloce dopo
data comunque su chiamate n so che
quando certo punto basta restare ferma
per mater matuta relazione basata su
chiamate e messaggi quindi ogni serie
mai visti il ragazzo quindi la vera
bugia la tua storia in atto no non
agiamo sommare vi dispiaccia gialappa
pancia possa fare raccontare di quando
nonostante con mia mamma delle sue
amiche fc tra i bimbi
io ero la più grande circa 12 anni
mentre scrivevano tipo una bimba jazz e
al 33 anni e mi parlavano stavano con me
c'era un acquario che io spostando una
postazione era molto pesato ancora lì
vicino disintegrato il ristorante è
facendo usciresti pesciolini ho detto
alla bambina di 7 anni e non dovessi
parlare e ora sono stato a tutti che ha
due bambini di tre anni avevano rotto
tutto spostando parte dal presupposto
che faccio né un ristorante con dei
bambini piccoli uno acquari un
posacenere pasticcio frantumato
ok quindi prese pezzettini no ed è già
una canzone di carmen consoli la bbc
grande che ho mai raccontato
purtroppo il caso mia mamma cosa avevo
14 anni e di un ragazzo che si era
trasferito a napoli e io stanno del nord
ho dovuto regolare questo enorme bugia e
mamma dicendo che andavo nel paese
accanto dall'amica pelle
merda preso un treno diretto a napoli e
come del capitale questa è una mamma lei
era salvini questa cosa devi dirgli che
di finanza vagoni meridionale ciao
vogliamo frate grossa cazzata che io
abbia mai detto è stata a delle mie
compagne delle superiori con il quale
dovevo andare in vacanza qualche estate
fa e alla fine io le mie amichette in
quanto che non volevamo che andare
vacanza con loro per poterti dire senza
essere presa come lo stronzo
dell'associazione ci siamo inventati che
ci avevano sgamate tutte 4 ubriache cioè
i nostri genitori ci avevano beccato
ubriaco in macchina che facevamo cose
poco carine con altri ragazzi e quindi
ovviamente la sua gente resteranno
arrabbiati non volevano andarci in
vacanza fermi ma non basta senti io non
posso più venire
eravamo nei quattro in quest'orgia di
buon tra quest'area la nenia le nostre
madri hanno preso cupo di atm
io non posso più camminare dopo questa
cosa aspetta un bambino
non posso partire nel mio figlio ciao
in realtà sia mai scoperta che mi dà
ragione mi vedevo anche non so cosa
tornavo a casa colmi tavo e mia mamma
dice lo sai che la francia debole se
prendi freddo e loro vomiti in realtà
non sapeva stare mi è venuta anche il po
anche se penso che la magia più brutta
che dico almeno una volta all'anno e di
rame nipoti che babbo natale non esiste
non esiste
non so cosa ascoltato
noi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo
video se nonostante tutto quello che
avete ascoltato credete ancora
nell'onestà della trasparenza
commentate scrivendo jessica e lapo
jessica fletcher
ok io grazia ti ringrazio per avere se
ti prestato a questa gara della mia
amicizia
noi ci vediamo la prossima settimana con
un altro video
ciao ragazzi